sélections nahon duplex à il est sur
scène il était avec nous hier
kenji est également un week-end où son
cousin kenzy et mon cv ça va mon frérot
et avec demain hier on a eu tellement de
trucs j'ai même pas le temps de dire que
t'étais pas ce que je voulais passer ton
crise se faire plein de trucs
gt non mais c'est en effet hier je
courais après le temps quoi comment ça
va mon gadget on est en mer si l'on
convient des taux on n'avait pas le
choix je c'est bon tu as eu la chance de
voir le porte parole du gouvernement
voyez tu sais qui je vais envoyer ton
album mi vida
il adore tu as tu lu envoyé à bien sûr
j'ai envoyé avec un petit mot je me suis
fait passer pour toi je sais mais passé
pour toi j'ai signé quasi t'emmerde pas
j'ai dit j'ai pas voulu y est déjà
déjà il vient d'être disque de platine
avec plus de 100 mille albums bord du mc
alger dans l'eau je lève mon kajiya que
des tubes
il ya évidemment et ken j étais là tu
étais où la kadji là là je suis à melun
devient on va fêter les 100 ans de jean
le procès si on va chanter toutes ses
chansons avec plusieurs artistes
ces chants mais j'adore l'endroit simple
et que je connais toutes ses chansons
ouais ça d'or qui se bécotent sur les
bancs publics bancs publics bancs
publics ont parfois des gueules de
sympathiques une autre puis autres à toi
cette chanson toi l'auvergnat qui sans
façons m'as donné quatre bouts de bois
quand dans ma vie il faisait crois
qu'elle gîte avec tila et avoue qu'il
est juste a serré la main
kenji et vincent nick lowe 1 2 stars de
la chanson lui versant 2 500 et vincent
il a fait t'as vu la fin titre avec des
prêtres
c'est du coup la hausse et crown et ben
il va te faire un truc sur lui fait
effet après que lille va car les deux
cents ans d'isabelle pour un homme aussi
kenji beauté qu'elle dit c'est pour une
émission que tu es là bas les sens tant
de gens blancs tu as well en fait les
100 ans de georges brassens et les
oreilles ou aujourd'hui je t'emmerde pas
kenji mais c'est quoi ce pour une
émission sur france 2 je voulais venir
de m'excuser pour ça c'est france 2 ça
france 3 oui non non c'est bon
excuse-moi catherine touchefeu ou tu es
tu sais que tu es là c'est pas la fête
de la chanson française
non si j'adore ça c'est sur france 2 à
france 3
c'est ça on se croise à françois georges
croissance et france 3 j'avoue j'ai
demandé à côté de moi aussi ça va ya des
règles il ya des règles strictes à
france 3 georges brassens et france 3
basse un petit peu plus john genre eddy
mitchell s'est rendu
et quand c'est dadullah ça sort
complètement du périmètre du service
public
là c'est autre chose et quand c'est que
cette ville mais kadji tu es super sympa
d'avoir été là bas parce que c'est
important que les mecs comme toi qui
rendent hommage à jean bouin sens est
vrai qu était un immense artiste moi
jouer à hull je connais tous ces
chantiers paris au moins demander une je
la sors un bravo ya un nouveau single
s'appelle évidemment évidemment
exactement il a écrit pour vous a chanté
pour la première fois hier notamment
moqué d'eux si je vais raconter
l'histoire cette chanson je vous jure
que c'est vrai kenji tête avec moi on a
été prendre un verre tous les oeufs et
qu'ainsi un moment ma pause et m'a posé
une question nous prenait un verre tous
les deux comme tu vois là on avait envie
de prendre un verre c'était avant le
confinement et kenji m'a dit franchement
cyril est ce que tu comptes figuraient
tous les chroniqueurs la rentrée
[Rires]
exactement et regardez ça a donné ce
titre ça a donné ce qu'ils regardent
[Musique]
pour mieux s'aimer
à 3 2 je pensais
évidemment fermé les yeux
sur le
être à deux c'est pas ton nez
à
[Musique]
souple
pour mieux s'aimer
cela joue à l'herbe
sachez que les petit adam padam padam
c'est des gens de ma famille qui les
journaux
m